(festive music)
- All right, Henry, come on in!
- Ready!
- Okay, Henry.
Happy Holidays!
As people can probably
tell, we're celebrating
the holidays a little early.
(bells ringing)
- Oh yes.
- Oh yes, because we wanna
spread a little Christmas cheer
because you have a new
holiday movie coming out.
- I do.
- So, I thought we'd celebrate
with a good old-fashioned
game of Nog Pong.
(festive music)
We're keeping it classy.
- Oh my God.
I don't think I've even
played regular Pong.
- [Kelly] Really, you've never?
- [Henry] Yeah.
- I think I've only
played it once.
- [Henry] Really?
- And I didn't win,
I'll tell you that.
- [Henry] Okay.
- Then I don't remember
the rest of the night.
(laughs)
- We'll be as bad as
each other, It's fine!
- [Kelly] It's really bad.
(festive music)
We are just missing
one crucial ingredient!
I'm gonna pour a tiny
bit just in all of 'em.
- Right, so you're spiking?
Holy moly.
- Okay, I am.
- Got it.
- Watch this Henry, this
is how we do it in Te-has.
- [Henry] Aye!
- [Kelly] This is how you do it in Te-has!
- Good lord!
- This is why I don't remember the night!
(laughs)
Okay, the rules are simple,
you toss a ball into one of my cups.
- [Henry] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And I have to drink
and vice versa, you got it?
- Got it.
- Okay and what we're playing
for, so glad you asked.
(laughs)
The winner gets to go
home with a highly coveted
first annual Nog Pong
World Championship belt!
- [Henry] Oh my God, look at that thing!
(angelic music)
- Let's take positions,
are you ready to start?
- Ladies first.
- Okay, well I'm gonna ask a question
while we're doing this.
- [Henry] All right,
go for it.
- 'Cause I'm trying
to throw you off your game, okay.
(laughs)
- You won't need to.
- What is Last Christmas about?
'Cause I'm excited.
Oh shoot.
- Oh.
- Oh good, I love it, I
love it, I'm using yours.
- Emilia Clarke's character
Kate, want to be a singer.
- Oh!
- She's kind of having
that quarter-life crisis
that we all, sort of,
often get ourselves into
and she meets a young man called Tom
who gives her a different
perspective on life
and there's George Michael music.
- George Michael, I'm in!
- Sold!
- We suck.
(bell ding)
- [Both] Oh!
- You spoke too soon!
(sigh)
- Everything is fine.
(laughing)
- The juice!
- I love this though,
(bell ding)
I'm excited to see this movie.
I'm also excited to get D-runk!
(laughs)
Whoa!
Okay.
- How well does that go down?
- It's so, there's a lot of bourbon.
- [Henry] It's good!
(bell ding)
- Yes!
- [Henry] Ah.
(bell ding)
- Where did you grow up?
- I grew up, I split time
between Malaysia and the UK.
So Surrey.
- Oh.
- So, from 10 onwards, I was in the UK.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- So those are the best years
of, like, Christmas presents.
- Yeah, I love the UK, God
and anytime you're in
England at Christmas time,
it's more magical.
(festive music)
So what is your favorite Christmas movie?
I'll go first, White Christmas.
- Elf is ex--
- Nailed it!
(bell ding)
- Ah.
- Yes!
I am like, I am--
- Damn!
- So good!
What was your job before acting?
- Oh, I used to work in
a salon doing blowouts,
cuts, drys, men hair, color.
- What?
Does your wife just love you?
Does she have you do that?
- More often than not,
I'm doing her hair for
whenever we're on a red carpet
- I love it!
- And you see my wife, like
I usually do the blowout.
- Oh my gosh!
What was your specialty?
(bell ding)
When you're a hairdresser.
You're kinda nailing this at this point.
- Aye.
- [Kelly] That's mine.
- It was kind of that
Chelsea, waves blowout
which was like, big and
voluminous and sexy.
- I'm gonna want you
to do that to my hair.
- Absolutely, any time you need me!
- I'm like, oh!
- Oh.
(festive music)
(bell ding)
Oh, that's pretty good!
- You know it, I am a woman of my word.
- Really, oh, do you?
Nah, you're a trooper.
Oh lord.
- You're kinda kicking
my behind at this game.
- I got one last one as well.
- Oh, shoot.
- If I get this last one,
you have to do whatever row it land on.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Henry] The row.
- I'm done, I'm done,
don't you challenge me with a good time!
(cartoon bounce)
- [Henry] Oh!
- Ah!
- [Henry] Dang!
- You know what?
You were closest to this
- [Henry] Yeah.
- And I'll just do it.
(laughing)
- Jeez!
- Congrats!
You are the first Egg
Nog Pong World Champion!
- Aye, woo woo woo!
- I mean, you kind of,
I think baited me a bit
and said you weren't really good and this
and then kind of killed me.
It's fine.
- I might have played a couple times.
Come on, come on.
- Do you want me to put it on?
Here we go.
- Of course I do.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm walking out with this,
what are you talking about?
- [Kelly] It's sticking on my sweater.
- This is only coming
back next when you guys,
(laughs)
when I do another Christmas movie.
(camera snaps)
(crowd applauding)